this video was made possible by
curiosity stream and nebula
to see a companion video to this one
about the surprising carbon footprint
of another famous streaming website
check out the video link in the
description
as of the start of 2021 youtube is the
second most popular website in the world
with over
1 billion hours of content consumed on
it every single day
so it would hardly be surprising if
youtube had a big impact on our climate
but how big is big reports in 2019
claimed that streaming one hour
of video on netflix or youtube generates
about 3.2 kilograms of co2
roughly the same emissions created by
driving a car for eight
miles this 3.2 kilogram figure came from
a french think tank called the shift
project who summarized that online video
had a quote
unsustainable and growing impact on the
climate
with total emissions of online video
equivalent to those of the entire
country of
france you've probably heard of this
figure because it was reported all over
the internet
in fact you quite possibly clicked on
this video with these articles on the
unsustainable impact of youtube on our
climate in the back of your mind
but they are wrong we'll come to the
correct carbon footprint for youtube in
just a minute
but before getting there i want to ask
why was
this damning report of youtube's carbon
footprint so
widely shared and i think that by
looking at the study
its flaws and how it was so widely
shared
we can learn a lot about how we interact
with and
frame climate change ultimately media is
driven by attention
papers that sell more copies make more
money websites that receive more traffic
make more in ad revenue so there's an
incentive in any form of media to
attract your audience by whatever means
necessary
it's kind of like an arms race for
attention and in terms of climate change
specifically
there are many reasons why a viewer
could be enticed to read an article or
click a link
but they broadly fall into two camps
firstly analysis
that indicates things are looking up
that things aren't as bad as we thought
they were
science is wrong rejoice we don't all
have to save money and make the world a
better place with higher life expectancy
and fairer income distribution
wait but secondly analysis that
indicates that things
are worse than we thought that we're
only years away from
complete climate catastrophe that
there's a 19
chance that humans will go extinct by
the end of
this century that figure by the way
is real it comes from a poll of
academics on global risk conducted by
the future of humanity institute at the
university of cambridge
and it's shocking we're talking about
the extinction of the human race
within this century and it probably made
you sit bolt upright and
it left you wanting to learn more
bad new cells except when discussing
climate change specifically
there's an extra factor that is really
important
nihilism there is a very pervasive
argument that the reality of climate
change is now so bad that we simply
shouldn't bother doing anything about it
the more headlines you read about the
extreme severity
of climate change the more you think
there's no point in changing your
behavior to avoid it
climate change is a train barreling down
on us and we're just tied to the tracks
reading that something as seemingly
innocuous as watching video online
is damaging the climate in ways that you
previously only associated with
flying and driving makes people think
well if i can't watch
tick-tock compilations on youtube then
what's the point
we're going to go extinct anyway give me
my cat videos i think
and to be clear this is me speculating
now that perhaps
people seek out these kinds of negative
headlines because
it excuses them from having to make any
changes to their behavior
hearing that youtube of all things has
the same impact on the climate as the
nation of
france makes the whole situation seem
hopeless the ship's sinking so let's
just have some fun on deck whilst it
lasts
perhaps that's why some of these
extremely negative headlines spread so
widely
people just didn't want to change
needless to say of course this is not
helpful because climate catastrophe is
not a foregone conclusion and there are
absolutely things that we can do
to reduce our impact on the climate and
writing off the whole thing as a
lost cause makes us less likely to do
those things
incidentally read don't even think about
it by george marshall to see
how we frame climate change is a really
important issue
let's dive into that 3.2 kilograms of
co2 emitted for every
hour of video streamed figure and see
why youtube's climate impact is really
not that bad
first of all the shift project
calculated the 3.2 kilogram figure by
looking at how much energy the data
centers used by netflix and youtube
consume
per byte of video then factoring in the
typical bit rates content is watched at
and finally estimating the co2 emitted
to generate the energy required
for those bit rates i'm simplifying but
that's basically it however the shift
project admitted that they'd made a mix
up in one calculation between bits
and bytes which reduced the 3.2 kilogram
estimate of co2 by a factor of eight
to just 0.4 kilograms per hour
secondly though great analysis by george
comey from the international energy
agency linked below
highlights some flawed assumptions made
by the shift project
perhaps most importantly they estimated
data centers
used far more energy than they actually
do thanks to out-of-date energy
efficiency data
overestimating the emissions of data
centers by a factor of 35.
there's more but the end result is that
depending on
where you are and what device you're
watching on and how you charged it
watching one hour of online video
emits just 36 grams
of carbon dioxide on average 90 times
lower than the initial shift
project estimate and in terms of youtube
specifically
google who owns youtube has set out to
power all of its data centers with
entirely renewable energy by
2030 and claims that it is entirely
carbon neutral to date
because of extensive carbon offsetting
now quite how effective that is is a
topic for a whole
other video but you could argue that if
you're watching youtube videos
specifically
that it's perhaps an order of magnitude
less carbon intensive
again of course however there are
complications and additional factors
that we have to think about
so while the immediate emissions of
watching youtube video may be pretty
small from the data centers
there are knock-on effects to consider
so if for example youtube encouraged
consumerist behavior through things like
haul videos
then that's a pretty big extra set of
emissions further down the line it's
almost like capitalism is bad for the
environment
if youtube radicalizes people towards
climate change denial then that will
have a negative effect on reducing
future emissions so effectively an
increase in emissions
and then of course there's stuff like
team trees
but at the same time youtube and other
streaming sites like
nebula and netflix and curiosity stream
are great disseminators of
information people are far more informed
about climate change
because of youtube channels like this
one and better ones because of
documentaries by people like david
attenborough
and the entire online ecosystem of
online video
do i think that outweighs the negative
knock-on effects
no but do i want to try and quantify
that
also no i'm going to leave that video to
someone far smarter than me
but perhaps we're missing the big
picture here yes youtube has very low
carbon emissions per video even added up
over a billion hours a day powered by
current grid generation not google's
promise renewables
it's a modest source of carbon emissions
a back of the envelope calculation
indicates maybe 13 million tons
of co2 per year roughly equivalent to
the emissions of tanzania
not france but maybe another reason that
those reports of streaming's carbon
footprint generated so much attention
is that online video is seemingly a
waste of time
i'd like to point out that as this is my
full-time job the online video is very
much not a waste of time and you
absolutely should continue to watch
online video and
like the videos and subscribe to the
channels and leave comments to engage
with the content having said that i'm
sure there are still people who are
watching this
and thinking to themselves yes but we
don't need
youtube it's just wasteful emissions no
matter how small they are
we have to get society back to its
absolute essentials if we're going to
beat climate change
we can't have these modern ideas of
what's necessary like
the youtubes and the tick tocks but as
vatclav smil
notes while throughout human history
we've trended towards greater and
greater energy consumption
and speed quote there is nothing new
about
unproductive energy uses and they could
be seen as wasteful only if human
societies were driven strictly by
one overarching goal to minimize the use
of energy devoted only to tasks or
processes directly relevant to a species
survival
in other words we are not optimal
perfectly efficient robots
we are humans and if you give humans
energy
they will always use some of it to do
something
stupid needless perhaps a website
founded on cat videos is just inevitable
some of the articles written about the
shift project estimate framed it as
climate warriors are coming for your
binge watching or this is what the
ecomaniacs want to take away next
and that's simply not true it's yet
another
harmful framing of climate change
a fundamental principle of climate
activism that's commonly misunderstood
is that we don't want to go backwards
the advances of the 20th and 21st
centuries have brought incredible
improvements to
quality of life via medicine and
education but even things are seemingly
frivolous as
youtube most of which has been enabled
by an incredible explosion in the energy
available to us
notably through electricity activists
like myself don't want to regress
our standard of living and i certainly
don't want a future without online video
what i want is a future where we can
continue using a similar amount of
energy but just
generate it from low carbon sources this
is why the renewable energy
transition is so important because our
modern standard of living is just
impossible to maintain without the
amount of energy that we currently use
whether that's in
healthcare or educational transport or
farming or youtube or whatever it may be
if we want to maintain our current
standard of living
but not ravage our climate we need to
move to low
carbon sources of energy that is what
environmentalists
want we don't want to take away the very
thing that makes
us human the frivolous use of energy
no one is trying to take away youtube
we're just trying to change
how we power it so to ultimately answer
the question
what is youtube's impact on the world's
climate well
the answer is complicated by how people
use the site and
knock on emissions but in terms of
direct impact
not as bad as you probably thought
thanks to
google's carbon neutrality pledge and
modern energy efficiency
but perhaps more than that not as bad as
you wanted it
to be perhaps you clicked on this video
hoping
that youtube was a colossal emitter of
carbon and by
watching even this very video you have
made an impossible problem
even worse so there was no point in even
trying to do something about it
well i'm sorry because this
problem is still very much solvable
there is still plenty of hope together
we can work towards a future where we
can
keep our quality of life and not pollute
our atmosphere in the process
we've just got to frame the story in the
right way and get a move on
move away from fossil fuels so we can
get on with what's really important
don't care youtube of course isn't the
only streaming website that's widely
used
for instance you might recognize
[Music]
for those of you that don't that's the
intro music from a website that i can't
talk about on youtube
let's call it horn pub the reason i
can't talk about horn pub is because
youtube's algorithm is likely to pick up
its name in the auto-generated captions
or in the description and suppress this
video from being recommended to a wider
audience
seeing as i can't talk about it on
youtube i made a follow-up video talking
about horn pub and its surprising carbon
footprint
over on nebula here i can make content
without worrying about interference by
the algorithm
and if you liked this video and thought
it was important you should go check it
out nebula is the streamy award
nominated platform co-owned by a
plethora of educational youtubers
including me
and it's a place where we upload
exclusive content like my horn pub video
but also
regular videos ahead of posting them on
youtube but most importantly
there are no ads on any of these videos
no pre-roll ads and no sponsor reads in
the videos
if you'd like to get access to nebula
then you can do so by our partnership
with
curiositystream curiositystream is the
perfect partner for us
being the home of thousands of top
quality high production value
documentaries
while we are the home of top indie
creators across a range of subjects
so in one fell swoop you can get access
to engineering future and learn about
how we can power the planet with low
carbon energy
and also get access to exclusive and
extended content on nebula from creators
like
yours truly real engineering and our
changing climate
doing so directly supports us creators
gives you a far better viewing
experience and is extremely
cheap using the link in the description
you can get access to both curiosity
stream and nebula for just 14.79 a year
that's 26 off a normal subscription
and directly supports smart educational
video
go to curiositystream.com simon clark to
sign up
and take your streaming experience to
the next level
thank you so much for watching the video
i really hope that you enjoyed it
if you did and you haven't already
definitely check out the companion video
that i made
about horn pub over on nebula here's
some suggested viewing next
as always if you did enjoy the video
please do pop it a like if you're not
already you can subscribe to the channel
and let me know what you thought
down there in the comments thank you
very much again for watching i'll see
you in the next one